c'est pas des
[Musique]
mur il aura été un héros malgré lui
Charles Piaget a été l'â du grand
mouvement DESP en
1973 même s'il rejetait ce titre de
leader qui lui à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
PE on a fait un leader bon en fait il
faut relativiser tout ça parce que j'ai
dû avoir
quelques qualité pour arriver à avoir ce
rôle un petit peu pivot mais comment un
combat c'est éminemment collectif entré
chez lip à 18 ans en 1946 après une
enfance compliquée une mère qui Senfu un
père horlogé qui n'a pas le temps de
s'occuper de lui et une famille
d'adoption qui sera son véritable foyer
Piaget apprend vite il devient
mécanicien ce syndque en 1953 à la CFTC
ouvrier hors paire il est promu
technicien puis contre maître en 1961
lip lip il y a du nouveau chez
[Applaudissements]
lip mais c'est à partir de 1968 qu'il se
révèle l'action collectif devient son
crédau délégué syndical CFDT il ne se
placera jamais au-dessus de la base et
s'opposera régulièrement à sa fédération
qui le trouve trop
libre ils étaient tous contre nous les
fédérations les la Confédération et
cetera il y a fallu il a bon ben tant
pis on a dit vous voulez pas d'accord
mais on y va quand même ça on va on va
le faire à cette époque il est également
adhérant du PSU le Parti socialiste
unifié en 74 il sera même un temps
pressenti pour être le candidat du parti
à l'élection présidentielle mais finira
à force de controverse par se
[Musique]
retirer la volonté de s'engager ne le
quittera jamais parti en prèretraite en
1983 il restera 10 ans éloigné de la
scène sociale avant de rejoindre assez
chômage dont il sera l'un des principaux
animateurs sa faculté d'indignation sera
restée intacte jusqu'au bout il sera de
toutes les manifestations et de tous les
premiers
maijdhui peut dire qu'il y a des une
aggravation des
problèmes un tel degré que vraiment on a
besoin de cette unité et d'être là le
premier ma car jusqu'au bout il aura cru
que grâce au collectif un autre monde
était
[Musique]
possible